My main objective and everything I've been embarking on and being a father
myself with,
it's all been kind of a fresh start.
I feel fresh.
It filled newer fields not in cause stopping that and could be in my way and
it's just awesome feeling.
So this is from doing that one DMT experiences sent you until I did one time,
but I didn't meet many times that,
that you know,
but yeah,
this really,
um,
I don't know what it is.
I'm trying to figure it out,
but I've changed but it's,
don't figure it out.
I just don't know how.
Yeah.
Um,
I describe it for a lot of people.
It's like resetting a computer.
You reset a computer,
you have a fresh new desktop and there's only one folder on the desktop and that
folder says my old bullshit.
Listen,
stop.
I'm finding my thought right now.
Sometimes I'm wondering this new feeling that I'm possessing right now,
if it,
I'm a real feeling this stuff really help.
Am I lying to myself again till the next moment,
the next feeling come to do some drug,
but the B,
it was somebody else.
And what's really going on as that feeling going to come back,
there's this moment that feeling feel like it never coming back.
It can never come back if you decide that it's never coming back,
but you have to make that decision pretty much every day,
but you can,
you can never come back if you want or you could slip into the old ways.
That's what a lot of people do.
One of the,
when a lot of people fall into drug additions,
relapsing,
when they relapse,
they're not physically addicted.
When they're relapsed,
obviously they're clean and then he decided to go back in.
It's cause there's comfort in those old patterns because this new way of life is
just,
they get anxiety.
They feel like it's a lot of pressure to stay clean.
Well,
that's explained it.
I hate that.
I always hated that.
Oh well I never wanted to do,
but then I do him again.
I never wanted,
I hated thousand now.
No,
no.
Come on.
You understand what I'm saying?
No,
I don't want to fuck.
I don't want that.
And then once you,
and once you do it,
then he's going all out.
Now you got the liquor there,
the girl,
ah man,
this is just a dark dog.
Vicious cycle.
It's real dark.
It's self destruct dog.
Yeah.
It's all about ego inflating and self deprecating enough to structure.
It also alleviates
you from the responsibility of improving the hundred percent.
That pressure of like keeping it together,
staying sober,
you know,
being disciplined,
all that stuff.
Once it's gone,
it's gone.
Like,
hi,
I'm just fucking crazy.
I'm crazy.
This is just what I do.
And it's easy to fall into that trap and that's what happens to a lot of people
who relapse with drugs.
I never want to go back to that again.
It's just no win situation.
That's one of the great things about marijuana that people don't understand.
They think that a drug is a drug as a drug.
They're all falling under the same category,
but you can use marijuana and just be peaceful and not chaotic.
And the opposite of make you think more about the consequences of ruining your
life.